what is the place value of 3 in 654
point 2 1 3 so let's think about that a
little bit and to do that let me rewrite
the number and I'll write each digit in
a different color so we have 654 point
we get the decimal point 2 2 1 want to
make sure I have enough colors here 2 1
3 now we're pretty familiar I think with
what goes on to the left of the decimal
point we know that this right here
reduce in a neutral color that this
right here is the hundreds this is the
hundreds place or we could view that as
10 to the 2nd 10 to the 2nd let me write
that a little bit bigger down here so
this right here is the hundreds that is
the hundreds place or you could view
that as the 10 to the 2nd place which is
the same thing as 100 this right here is
the tens place which is the same thing
as 10 to the 1st this right here is the
ones place which is the same thing as 10
to the 0 then if you go to the right of
the decimal point one place to the right
of the decimal point this represents
tenths this represents tenths or we
could view it as I could write it like
this this represents tenths or 10 to the
negative one then if we go to this
magenta if we go to places to the right
this represents hundredths
this represents hundredths or 10 to the
negative 2 and then finally this 3 this
represents thousandths this represents
thousands or 10 to the negative 3 now
just to answer the question what is the
place value of 3 in 654 point 2 1 3 the
place value is thousandths the place
value is thousands and we'd that would
essentially answer their question but to
make sure that we really understand what
this means I'm going to rewrite this
number we can rewrite this number as 600
right we have six hundreds plus five
tens or
you could say plus 50 plus 50 plus four
ones so plus four ones plus like the
four is net other color plus four ones
plus two tenths so plus two tenths plus
one hundredths plus one hundredths plus
three thousandths
plus three over one two three
thousandths or we could write this just
to really make sure we understand what
we're talking about when we mean place
value we can rewrite this number as six
times 100 plus five times 10 plus four
times one I keep doing that in the wrong
color plus four times 1/4 times one plus
two times 1/10 plus 2 2 times 1/10 plus
plus 1 times 1 over 100 and then finally
plus 3 times 1 over 1,000 so hopefully
this when you write it out like this
gives you a sense of what it means when
we say place value the six to one to
three digits to the left of the decimal
is in the hundreds place so it
represents six hundreds this represents
five tens because it's in the tens place
this represents four ones you go to the
thousands place this three literally
represents three one thousandths